I got four points I want to make to you
by the time I'm done with my message
here one of them is the following how
many of you guys would love it if you
and I had the manual and the Playbook of
what our enemy used against us who would
love to have that who will love that
right okay I'm going to share with you
two enemies we all have which we'll talk
about I'll break that down for you how
to go about it with this enemy and then
the challenge to everybody at then end
of the talk that I have for everybody
here what you do with it is completely
up to you but I do want to give
everybody a challenge here by the time
we wrap up so having said that my
message my story can you make some noise
if you're a student today I'm just
wanting to know the audience who's a
student
today okay well let me let me be more
specific cuz somebody maybe 63 years old
saying I'm still reading books I'm a
student make noise if you're under 25
years
old I saw a couple 40-year-olds making
noise but it's okay we can feel that way
Make Some Noise if you're 25 to
okay just so anybody 45 exactly
45 the best age you can be by the way is
45 it's proven it's going to be 46 next
year but right now it's
45 Make Some Noise if you're proud to be
above
wow
by the way very very revealing on why
that's going to make me call a quick
audible on my message to those of you
above 45 unbelievable to have as loud of
a chant that you had here as well as
below 25 we'll talk about you guys and
here in a minute how many of you have no
clue who I am Make Some Noise you have
no idea who I am so I can give you a you
don't know who I am you how many of you
listen to pbd podcast
anybody okay who watches a little bit of
value tainment
more pbd podcast it's okay it's okay so
let me give you a little bit about my
background born and raised in Iran um I
was born during the revolution October
1978 in tan Iran when my uh Mother's
water broke my dad's taking my mother to
the hospital there's curfew he gets held
up he has to show that my mom's pregnant
with me goes to the hospital I'm born
next you know 3 months later the Sha's
in Exile we stay Iran's chaotic for the
next 10 years 10 and A2 years June 2nd
or 3rd of '89 Ki dies 6 weeks later my
mother said we can't stay here anymore
we escaped because my mother was afraid
of me serving in the military in Iran my
dad's like listen do what you guys got
to do you guys got to go we go to
Germany we live in a refugee camp in
Germany in ER longan
Germany had a great time for about a
year and a half and we come to to the
states November 28th 1990 a day I'll
never forget when we're crossing we go
to New York the moment I land in New
York I'm walking around in the airport
I'm looking for Gremlins I'm looking for
Rocky I'm looking for all these guys I'm
thinking America like this dream of mine
right I watched Rocky 4 a few hundred
times in fary little weird but I watch
it in farsy a few hundred times and then
finally come here we live in glendle
California not glendle Arizona glendle
California any any Californians here yes
or
no by the way any Texans here
Texans any Floridians
here here's here's what I can tell you
if California and Texas could have a
baby it's Florida that's why I live in
Florida now just so you know I've lived
in California I've lived in Texas and I
live in Florida and I love it in Florida
but I still have a I love the other two
states I lived in as well let me
continue so I go to high school I get
out
um I decide to join the Army I go to the
101st Airborne Division Air
Assault thank you anybody else here
served who El served here anybody served
thank you for your service one of the
best decisions I made in my life I end
up getting out of the army when I get
out it was because of my citizenship
date I had June of uh 1999 I become a US
citizen so for some of you wondering if
you can join the army with a green card
you can't cuz I was in the army with a
green card just so you know some people
just freaked out a little bit but that's
what happened with me so I get out and I
don't know what I want to do at that
time I was a bodybuilder that was my
dream I was going to go be Mr Olympia
going to Hollywood marry a Kennedy be a
governor and
[Applause]
then I I met a girl named Jean Vier who
introduced me to Morgan sty Dean Witter
uh day before 911 I start working at
Morgan sty Dean Witter I get my series
766 3126 life and health I Fen up with
the financial industry um next States
911 I leave Morgan Stanley I go to Trans
America World Financial I'm there for
about 7 and a half years I see what's
going on with the
marketplace and then in September of
2009 start our own insurance company and
then you know it takes off but I want to
tell you a couple things that happened
in 2009 March of
2009 my wife and I we start dating I've
kind of found the industry I'm want to
be a part of I love numbers and I love
the financial industry I love people so
that's that's a great combination I
found the girl that I think I'm going to
marry we've been dating out for 4 years
we've known each other for about 5 and a
half years I am making money I've heard
the magical words from my parents I'm
proud of you but at this point I'm
realizing this thing cannot be about
money and I'm trying to figure out what
I need to do so I bring a handful of
people I respect a lot one of them was
my pastor a couple of the gentlemen that
I had I said listen I need your help I
need to find my purpose there's no way
in the world God put me here to just
just go make money I want to find out
exactly what that reasoning is this is
too chaotic and a strange life I've
lived why did you do this to me I want
to know one of the mentors takes me to
an event at myar hotel Santa
Monica uh with Claremont Institute
anybody knows Claremont Institute Larry
AR all those folks anyways I don't know
whether you like him or not it was a
good event for me I go to this event a
man named George Will gets up there and
speaks talks about how lawyers are r
ruing America any lawyers in the room if
you know some of you guys are ruining
America but that's a whole different
story I don't want to
digress and then afterwards I meet and
the gentleman that introduced me says
hey you know George Patrick wants to
know what to he should commit his life
to what purpose he says where are you
from I said hean he says why don't you
go study why so many people around the
world come to America why do we only
call America the American dream no other
place I leave and that becomes my
obsession that's March of 29th
3 months later my wife and I get married
on June 26th of 09 three weeks three
weeks by the way our youngest daughter
was born June 26 on our wedding day
which is kind of like it's no longer
that necessary now it's her day used to
be our anniversary now it's her day 3
weeks later we put an event together I'm
on fire at this time we put an event
together at JW Marriott called saving
America doing the impossible I'm dressed
as a middle eastern George Washington
okay unfortunately you can find this
picture on Google that's the
disappointing part my wife is dressed as
Lady Liberty she looks like Lady Liberty
because she's from Texas when we got
married it was kind of funny because I'm
from Iran and and she's from Texas and
there's about 500 people at the wedding
and and all the blue-eyed greeneyed
people on one side they're not dancing
all the hairy people on the other side
you know why are you laughing all the
hairy people on the other side they're
not getting up finally one of my friends
that night who was one of my groomsmen
was sponsored by uh couple guys you may
recognize Jack and Jose and he spent a
little too much time with these two guys
if if you know what I'm saying you know
what I'm saying if you don't know what
I'm saying you know what I'm saying okay
so he gets up and he says look some of
you guys are
worried you don't want to dance you're
wondering if this marriage is going to
work out or not trust me I'm worried as
well when they first started dating I
said why would a girl from Texas nice
little girl why would she marry this big
scary looking guy from Iran why would
she do that he says I finally figured
out what these guys have in common they
have two things in common everybody's
waiting Texas Iran they both like oil
and weapons of mass destruction it's
going to work out it's going to be all
right okay obviously a terrible joke but
everybody laughed we got up we danced
all that it was amazing anyways
so we put this event 3 weeks after we
get
married I got a 40ft m brush on the
stage 40 American flags I bring a
speaker to talk about the star spangle
Banner another one to talk about
capitalism uh the son of Ronald Reagan
just to tell stories about Ronald Reagan
just tell stories that's all I want you
to do tell stories about your father
right 3 months after that we started an
insurance company and we grew that
insurance company from 66 agents to
today we have roughly 50,000 agents
Nationwide few hundred offices
Nationwide and we've
been very grateful last year when we
partner with a great organization called
Integrity I've been fortunate enough to
do a lot of incredible things in my life
travel dreams that don't make any sense
to me I'm married today with four kids
life is amazing God's been unbelievable
to me if there's anything in my life
I've been talking a lot about lately
when I'm going around is I'm finally
openly talking about my biggest fear I
have in life I don't fear a lot of
things if there's one thing I fear in
life and I can't even tell you how
unbelievable of a fear this is I
fear losing God's favor it is the
biggest fear I have and by the way I'm
not the only reason I share that with
you is because when I look at that flag
I think
America for God knows how many years has
been known as the greatest country in
the world it has forgotten and no longer
fears losing God's favor we are now
afraid to pray in schools but we're okay
with teaching all these other things to
our kids I'm not okay with that I'm a
pretty easygoing guy we can sit down
tell jokes pull a couple pranks play
Domino Play Back yaming Talk Sports Talk
politics if you cross the line and
impose yourself on my kids you're going
to meet a very different human being
period right and I'm convinced many of
you feel the same way as well having
said that let me talk about a couple
different things here when I say to you
about the enemy if I were to ask you
right now who do you think is the Enemy
of the State who's the number one enemy
we got in America today I want you to
scream it out tell me who you think it
is who do you think it is say it say it
louder who do you think it
is all right let me give you a few names
and tell me if you agree some of these
guys our enemies would you say
mainstream media is one of the
enemies would you say the
establishment's one of the enemies would
you say those on the outside China Iran
whatever other countries are who hate
what America stands for is one of our
enemies yes or no would you say some of
the people on the inside that hate what
what America stands for yes or no how
about our educational system and all
those unions are they one of our enemies
how many more you want me to go through
I got a list of them if you want me to
go through lgbtq
indoctrination I can talk about Larry f
central banks defense contractors
lobbyists rhinos I can continue
Hollywood entertainment globalism keep
going with all these names
however at 28 years old I made a
decision in my
life I was constantly asking this
question of why I'm here and what drives
me
is the goal in life Patrick To Be A
Millionaire no is the goal in life to be
a billionaire no and by the way I'm
talking about the Pinnacle I want to
know what's the top of the top what is
the one thing worth me giving my entire
life
to is it me wanting to be a great father
number one no is it to be a great
husband no is it to be a great
capitalist not the number one is it to
live a fulfilled life it's not the
number number one is it to be funny fun
all that stuff not number one and I kept
going through it all that stuff is great
but it's not my number one see what's
crazy is a lot of us in here have a lot
of people we
love and a lot of you in here have a lot
of people that love
you everybody has that but there's a
very big difference between being loved
and being respected and being
admired one can love their husband but
maybe they're saying man he no longer
lights it up like he used to he used to
work and drive and go and get after he
was Fearless he used to be like that 15
years ago but all of a sudden he lost
that fire in his eyes what happened with
that but she'll never tell you she
admired a man of 15 years
ago your parents may love you but your
father when he looks at you gives you a
look and says why doesn't my son give
his best I wish I admired my son
son but he loves
you there comes a point in your life
where you got to say I want to be loved
and I want to be
admired there was nothing in my life
more
important than being a leader amongst
leaders and when you're when you realize
if the number one is being a leader
amongst leaders does that mean you need
to be a great father
absolutely does that mean you need to be
a great husband absolutely great wife
yes great capitalist yes great
contributor to society yes have a
backbone to stand up yes because the
number one Pinnacle in life is what
being a leader amongst leaders you know
who's looking for that right now the man
upstairs I'm convinced the man upstairs
looking down right now saying what
happened to this incredible country that
loved God and they would constantly talk
about it man I am looking for a new
generation of leaders to rise up I
believe God is looking for the next
generation of flag carriers yeah and to
be people like that you have to be
leaders amongst leaders by the way this
is a tough decision for us to make
because we don't like that kind of
responsibility we don't like that kind
of pressure however what clip did
glenbeck play at the end why do you and
I watch that movie and get emotional why
do you watch the movie Gladiator and we
get fired up when we watch Gladiator why
do you love that scene why do you love
the scene when he gets up and he turns
around show your face
Gladiator and he takes it why do you
love that scene Because deep down inside
of you I don't know what it is he put
something in us that we want to be
leaders amongst leaders but we're scared
sometimes and that's okay it's okay to
be scared at times but someone's going
to wake your ass up every once in a
while if today that's me to you it was
somebody else 15 years ago I don't have
a problem being that person FYI some of
you guys are saying Pat I consider
myself a leader amongst leaders that's
great but everybody came to this even
with a different outcome
some of you came here quite frankly
let's just say it is because for
whatever reason Turning Point USA
attacks a lot of young good-looking
people you know what I'm saying kind of
like well you know I hope I meet
somebody I hope I meet
somebody some of you came here because
you came with your granddaughter or your
grandson or your daughter and you're
wanting your kids to be in an
environment that you can trust for them
to become great leaders you're hoping
something happens fire fire is lit under
your kid you're hoping that happens to
you some of you guys are here it's
because it's you you're like man I'm
looking for something to get me to the
next level I want to wake up and do
something big with my life I feel like I
haven't had it for a while everybody's
got a different outcome but we just
talked about the first enemy the first
enemy is what we love talking about
outside enemies right which is what yeah
that globalist yeah mainstream media
yeah this yeah that no problem they are
enemies but they're only one of the
enemies
but the only reason they win is because
of the second enemy let me unpack the
second enemy for you here's the second
enemy I'm
convinced the second enemy are three
communities number one is the tolerant
Christians are one of those
enemies good people sweetheart you've
learned 20 30 40 different scripture oh
God praise the Lord praise the Lord John
3:16 oh Proverbs
yeah it's okay they can also it's okay
what interpretation do you have of who
Jesus was do you think Jesus was a guy
that was going around saying yeah yeah
it's okay it's okay it's okay or do you
think he stood up and he managed
expectations with other people are we
confused in these churches are we
confused so to me the number one enemy
is these tolerant Christians they're not
being called out they not being called
out I go to so many different churches
well why is donation down why is this
down why do you think it's down FYI we
can sit there and be upset about Muslims
as much as possible and act like we're
victims you know what they're doing
they're Simply Having more kids than you
why are you upset so can you imagine if
somebody says well these Muslims look
how they're growing so fast just 50
years ago we were three times the size
of them and now they're the same as us
and in the next 30 years they're going
to be running Senate and Congress and
governors why do you sound like you're
scared why don't you go have four five 6
seven eight babies wh why why do you why
do you stop saying lines like the
following where it's like well you know
my husband and I we want to spend 5
years together and then at 35 years old
we'll think about having a kid cuz you
know it's a lot of work having a kid
what do you think is the biggest juice
of life you think it's a nice house you
think it's a nice car or you think it's
having a kid oh my God one of the
greatest gifts we have if you're able to
do it with health I don't want to impose
this on some people who God won't even
help you have kids because you're
wanting to have kids there's so many
people I want to have kids that can't
but if you can't have kids go four 5 6 7
8 9 10
go raise them with the right values be
tough on them challenge them love on
them spend some time talking to them
about all the things that's taking place
in America today and the world don't be
afraid of it cuz if you don't do it the
school's going to do it and you're going
to be like how the hell did I lose my
kids for a decade or two cuz you didn't
talk to your kids about all the things
that they were facing so number one
enemy on the other side are tolerant
Christians let me talk about the second
one are the do your thing
Libertarians look man you know as long
as you do your thing I don't care what
you do you want to smoke week go ahead
you want to go do this go ahead go do
shrooms if you want to do your thing now
I don't think this is a Libertarian
Community but Libertarians also have
been saying do your thing do your thing
do your thing and guess what the schools
are saying well thank you so much guess
what we're going to do we're going to do
our thing with your kids thank you so
much Libertarians you guys are awesome
you guys are so awesome because you said
do your thing and we are you're not
running for the board in school we are
and we control what's being taught to
your kids we love do your thing
Libertarians they're ruining America
number three you know this next
one these are the
now I'm going to tell you this in a
different angle these are the and by the
way it's not a lot of the crowd here but
there's a lot of them out there because
I know some of you guys who you are and
what you're doing it's the lazy
scared Rich
conservatives let me explain before
you're offended and you go slash our
tires outside and I can't make it to my
hotel
room you know what this community
is you know it's a community where it's
kind of like no look you know we can't
tell people what we believe in because
we may lose those guys over there that
invite us to the cool parties we can't
tell them what we believe in we can just
say yeah you know we kind of this this
that
wishiwashi what what do you stand
for what is you what do you stand for do
you have a backbone what do you stand
for by the way while you're sitting
there investing your money in all these
other things Mark
bennyhoff Jeff Bezos buys wo for how
much $500 million that's
nothing Time Magazine few hundred
million nothing LA Times bought for $500
million nothing I may be out by 50
million bucks but that's nothing to many
of the rich Republican billionaires that
are in the room or out there you mean to
tell me you couldn't about La time
you mean to tell me Forbes Family sells
Forbes to a Chinese company that owns
90% of it and they announc the
international Woman of the Year Hillary
Clinton what what are we talking about
so you can't go by Forbes you can't go
by Fortune why would we be these buy
these types of companies because media
is communicating the messaging to people
you got to pick up somebody these
platforms well no but it's the rate of
return no it's also a portion of your
money needs to be invested in things
that's not about a rate of return
it's about what this country's done for
you you got to go and buy some of these
platforms so we can persuade and build
an Next Generation so now these two
enemies we know one of them on the
outside great second one is us if you're
always saying it's the enemy it's the
enemy it's the enemy on the outside what
you're telling the world is you're
helpless and this community we're not
helpless that's not a language we use
we're doers do you understand that so we
cannot use that language when we're
going out there let me continue next
part next
part I think we have to do a better job
selling our values and
principles Charlie does a great job
selling it I think he's one of the best
he's fantastic Elana is doing it in his
own way others are doing it in their own
way we need to get better at selling
some of the values and principles that
we have because our values and
principles are
proven the way we raise kids the way we
raise communities the way we built you
know us a brand spanking new startup
country 1776 into the greatest country
in the world how do we do this China had
been around with a couple thousand years
Iran been around for 2 200 years we do
it brand spanking a startup called
United States of America yes our ideas
are proven everybody else works for our
companies they work for our companies
Walmart employs nearly 3 million people
worldwide I think 2 million is here
another Millions outside of here we
create jobs for others we need to tell
that story better we're getting better
but we're not there yet now couple other
things how many of you love bullies who
loves
bullies how many of you love
bullies how many of you know there are
certain bullies right now that we're
dealing with yes or no there's two rules
I got with my kids when it comes out to
bullies we don't bully other people but
we also don't get bullied
however
um Co was
obviously a terrible event that took
place One Life lost is one too many okay
however let's set that
aside Co was also
maybe one of the best events that took
place if you look at it from the
perspective of knowing the Playbook the
enemy wanted to use against
you
so they all of a sudden went like this
with their hand and they were Shameless
about it and if we saw their hand and we
don't do anything about it whose fault
is it so now here's a mistake we
typically make if you're a
Christian we tend to be very
forgiving we have something called
Grace right we're forgiven we have Grace
well say it's okay let's just move
on we need
accountability we need to find out what
happened
we need to find out if they did the
right thing or not we need to find out
what happened with fouchi I simply want
accountability we need to find out what
China did why are we forgetting about
the fact what happened with Wan I simply
want accountability because without
accountability you know what you're
telling the world you know what you're
telling a world when there's no
accountability it's like if your kid
does something and there's no punishment
guess what you're telling them you can
do it again and again and again that's
what we're teaching everybody there is
no accountability this concept about
being afraid of somebody these companies
going out of business they need to go
out of
business anybody knows what a zombie
company is a zombie company is companies
that only Survive by borrowing money if
they don't keep borrowing money they
don't paid operating expenses or nothing
so they go out of business if they don't
borrow okay in 1997 only 1% of companies
in America were zombie companies you
know what the number is today
25% 25% % of companies in America are
simply surviving by constantly borrowing
money let them go out of business let
them go out of business let the right
people operating operating the right
businesses we need to kind of talk about
some of these companies that are not
doing it right I'm sorry you're not a
good operator go work for the other guy
you're not meant to be a Founder you're
not meant to be a CEO you're meant to be
an executive in the other guy's company
you're still going to make money but
it's a different mindset to be an
operator that's the part of
accountability nope but we're afraid for
people to fail the whole concept about
capitalism is four things freedom to
buy freedom to sell freedom to try and
what's the last one freedom to fail they
got to fail if they don't fail there is
no capitalism so we have to sit there
and say listen these guys that to make
it that's totally fine but watch this
let's talk about these bullies the one
thing about bullies is the following
what most people don't realize about
bullies
is so imagine you talk to a bully and
here's what a bully tells you if you do
that I'm going to whoop your ass if you
do that I'm going to call all my guys to
come after you they're around the corner
and you're like oh my God I'm so sorry
I'm so sorry please don't do anything
yeah yeah I'm so sorry okay I'm just
gonna I'm so sorry and then all of a
sudden sometimes you tell the bully to
fall you say that one more time I'm
going to get the guys I got 20 people
around the corner waiting to whoop your
ass and you just say call
him call
him what do you mean matter of fact
let's go find your 20 guys let's go
together around the corner you ready
let's
go wh what what do you mean but maybe
they're not there right now because
you're bullshitting me guy there is no
other person behind you your argument
isn't that valid of an argument bullies
aren't as tough as people think they are
but they're very good at selling you on
that concept they're very good at
convincing you they're powerful they're
not so watch this what method do they
use so why are so many people scared to
sell their values and principles to
other here's
why the game plan they use is
shame Glenn talked about it briefly
earlier they'll shame you so people like
what if they find out that what if they
find out that I got a DUI 22 years ago
what if they find out that I file
bankruptcy done what if they find out
what if they find out what if they find
out what if they find out and then all
of a sudden you'll catch yourself living
this life you know what this life is
handcuffs and shackles cuz you're afraid
of Shame
and you have this notion in your life
that you're supposed to live a perfect
life I'm not living a perfect life I'm
trying to live a magical life and doing
my best to improve but by them doing
this to you and the reason why what what
Donald Trump did that was very unique is
he said what do you want to shame me
with go ahead boom he put it back on
them boom he put it back on them boom he
put it back on them boom he put it back
on like what am I going to do with this
guy character assassination Financial
assassination what's left in this
Playbook we've done everything to this
guy and he would stand up right there
and some people started realize maybe I
need to just stand up so they'll use
shame against you they'll use guilt
they'll use apathy they'll use grief
anger distracting you judgment
constantly every one of those things and
you'll sit there and say eventually you
know what I'm not doing it so imagine if
there's a press conference let's just
say you're running for office I'm going
to paint a picture to you watch this one
here um
so all the stuff that's going on they're
embarrassing you every article article
article article article article article
negative defamation of character
Non-Stop and this one reporter is asking
a question I'm sorry what's your name
Mary Jane fantastic Mary Jane all these
things you're challenging me on for my
lack of perfection in my life fair you
can keep doing that can I ask the
audience a question yes and you look
dead at the camera and he said any
anybody who ever went to high school
with Mary Jane anybody who has any dirt
on Mary Jane anybody who was ever Mary
Jane's ex anything that Mary Jane ever
did in the past finances stole money
from you maybe you're a cousin your a
niece you're all this stuff whatever
dirt you have on her that she
backstabbed you odds are Mary Jane
there's somebody that hates you can you
please start sharing some of that
information with us on Twitter can you
do that and she's like no you can't say
that I'm not trying to say that
but if you obviously the way you're
shivering right now Mary Jane watching
your body language are worried about you
not living a perfect life why are you
doing it to me why don't you question my
policies what do you not like about my
policies let's debate it what do you not
like about my ideas let's debate it but
if we're going to have this argument of
whether you walk on water or I do
neither one of us are qualified so knock
it off and let's move on can we do that
well you know you know we need to impose
impose and put the fear back in them not
the other way around we need to
challenge them and kind of get them
thinking and say whoa I'm kind of
nervous a little bit because of what
this guy did he flipped it on me yes
flip it on them what do you want to know
about me yeah I've made some mistakes
what else you want to know we need to do
more of that this concept of being
perfect and by the way we have a couple
candidates one mention them one of them
I like a
lot but unfortunately the reason why his
campaign doesn't do well
is because he has this idea of walking
on
eggshells he has to be perfect and guess
who doesn't relate to him the American
voter I'm sorry to say this to you some
of you guys say I don't know who you're
for we have some candidates that walk on
egg shows they just want to be sold as a
perfect candidate I remember one time I
want to flight back with Bill O'Reilly
this is 2012 this is when he was doing
the stuff with Dennis Miller I'm going
from Burbank to Vegas for a convention
bill o're sitting right next to me I'm
like Bill what happened with Romney and
Obama he said I'll tell you a story
about what happened with Romney and
Obama so what's that he says we called
both camps and we said guys you're not
going to get elected if you don't come
on Fox and Romney's camps said no they
didn't come on but Obama's c campaign
manager called me back and we had a
conversation together and says what the
campaign manager say he says the
campaign manager said it's done Bill's
like no it's not if you don't Bing bring
Obama on the show you guys are not
winning he says it's over he says what
do you mean it's over he says well he
had a shot the shot was on a second
debate do you remember when Obama went
down on the second debate and Romney
came
up he says the third debate apparently
his marketing team or whatever his
campaign manager told them you're not
getting the single women's vote you were
a little too tough on Obama and they
don't like it change your approach he
says the moment he fell for those
Consultants he failed it was over with
you know how many candidates we got that
there listening to Consultants you know
what America wants to know about what do
you stand for tell me what you stand for
the consultant's not running what are
you running for I like talking to vivec
because I feel like vivec's talking to
me I like talking to certain candidates
because I feel like they're talking to
me you talk to the establishments like
the talking point here's a 17 points to
hit here's the script here's the line
here's a this dude we don't want a robot
as a president we want a real human
being that I can relate to and I can say
this guy's going to get it done I'm not
expecting perfection out of you but I
want you to be a leader and get it done
that's what we want as Americans at
least that's what I believe we want as
Americans
so if the standard you're willing to
take here tonight when we leave is
wanting to be a leader amongst leaders
there's a couple things we got to be
thinking about number one
anticipation 2024 is going to be very
chaotic it's going to be weird there's
some weird movies coming up how many
guys saw the recent movie leave the
World behind anybody saw that movie
there oh okay yeah you know all these
what you am I watching a movie or is
this a documentary realistic thing and
then I'm seeing Mark Zuckerberg just
spent $100 million building a house in
Hawaii with a nuclear bunker what does
he know that the rest of the world
doesn't know about talk about the timing
oh accidentally coincidentally a week
after that movie comes out a new movie
comes out what's the name of that movie
civil war Civil huh
Leave the World Behind our power grid in
America hasn't been updated 75% of it
hasn't been updated in got 50 years and
and you're kind of talking about that
then you're pinning whites against
blacks there's a line in the movie that
says Dad you know if something goes down
we can't trust these white people I know
that's something both you and Mom agree
on why do you put that line in the movie
Barack and you were helping with the
script why would you put that in the
movie Why would you put that in the
movie Barack aren you the same guy that
gave a talk at the DNC in 2004 about
bringing people together what happened
to that guy when you gave that speech by
the way there's something that our brand
bytim and pbd podcast is slightly
different in here's what it is I like
talking to everybody I like talking to
everybody some I can't believe we talk
to that guy I'm like dude if you like I
like talking to anybody who knows some
of the weird people we've spoken to
anybody's ever seen Anthony Weiner on
our podcast yes or no was that a weird
podcast or what how many you guys saw
tubin on our podcast we enjoy talking to
him how many you guys saw cuom on our
podcast how many you guys have seen
Sammy Deano on our podcast how many you
guys have seen I don't know uh Alex
Jones on the podcast or DOA or or Kobe
Bryant or I don't know all these I like
talking to everybody I feel like the the
role everybody's playing a different
role in this battle we're going to face
in the next decade two or three we're
all dressed in different uniforms we all
love America but we all are playing a
different role everyone's got a
different superpower I feel like the one
we're playing is like this hey man can
we sit down and talk can we do that I
read a book with tip O'Neal and and uh
Ronald Reagan they could talk right can
we sit down have a conversation together
yes okay tell me about your upbringing
tell me about your upbringing
interesting you guys have that in common
as F with fathers yeah I guess we do
what sport do you like oh no you
too you guys have that in common an hour
later do you realize you guys agree on
73 different things what do you disagree
on politically five different things
let's hash it out and debate it's okay
some like Red Sox some like Yankees
let's debate it out some like Lakers
some like well today you can't like the
Lakers but some used to like the
Lakers don't get me started I don't want
to go there but you get the idea what
I'm I'm trying to get people talking to
one another but by the way what happens
before a husband and wife get a divorce
what's the easiest sign what's the
easiest sign that divorce around the
corner what is they stop talking and if
you don't talk to each other what do you
not do at
night back to back you know how hard it
is to have sex back to
back not a lot of give to people like
that but you can't have sex back to
back that was a little bit mathematical
and scientific if some of you guys got
it good for you if you didn't get it God
bless you it's going to be all
right I want to talk to
everybody I want to sit down down and
talk and say let's talk I
disagree you disagree with me let's
start the discussion okay A a part of
the challenge is that we also feel we
can only talk to people that agree with
us how does that make any sense if we
only talk to people that agree with us
then then what opportunity are we given
to baptize people in the name of
whatever the United States of America if
we're only going to talk to people that
agree with us where is the debate how
are you getting better how am I getting
stronger we got to sit down and have
some of these conversations maybe this
is not a message some of you guys agree
with I'm comfortable with that I want to
do that I didn't say don't be paranoid I
didn't say be
naive if you have the ability to reason
and manage expectations with people in
your life you can call out BS and still
have a respectful conversation with
somebody who's ever seen a movie
Roadhouse with Patrick S who's seen the
movie roadh house how many you guys love
the movie Roadhouse okay man I love the
movie Roadhouse you know what's one of
the best scenes in a
movie is when the uh all the all the
what do you call it all the security
guys the the bouncers are sitting there
and they're talking to Patrick suy and
what does he say to him ask him to leave
but be
nice if they try to do this ask him to
leave but be nice what if he calls your
mama
is she if you know the movie you know
what line that is whatever they do just
be nice we can have unless if you're
Anthony Wier and you disrespect then we
don't have to be nice cuz you cross the
line but if you come to me and you're
respectful let's have a conversation
together and see what we can do that's
half the battle if we don't talk to each
other we're going through a divorce very
soon and if you're a leader amongst
leaders you don't fear talking to people
whom you and they disagree with it's
okay to talk to them half the reason why
Charlie is doing such a great job he
goes and talks to everybody on these
campuses you think it's easy being on
the other side what is the possibility
of somebody doing something to Charlie
it takes courage what this Turning Point
USA organization does on a regular basis
with these kids takes a lot of Courage
so I'm down to my last three minutes
here and I I got a bunch of other things
but I'll just wrap it up here with a
couple points points and we'll send it
off and and go from there you know for
me um there's different ways that we can
contribute all of us some of you are
here you get to contribute with time you
don't have money you're like like I
don't have any money but I'm 19 years
old I can contribute with time awesome
do it some of you may be retired and you
have some money but you can contribute
with your time you can't speak like
Charlie Kirk or you can't speak like
glenbeck or some of these incredible
speakers but you can give your time some
of you don't have time but you have
money that's one way you can give money
to whatever different programs he's
working with or anything else you're
doing you can give with money but some
of you guys that have a
voice this next few years I am
convinced I'm so convinced my favorite
hat slogan that we have on every one of
our gears it says future looks bright I
don't know why I am so optimistic about
what's about to happen next I think
we're going to see a movement of some of
the most incredible leaders being born
during these chaotic times we going to
meet leaders where we going sit there
and say where did where did he come from
where did she come what was this all
about we needed to have a massive crisis
for us to wake up and realize what was
worth fighting for and both freedom and
America is worth fighting for thank you
so much everybody appreciate you thank
[Music]
you